economía en directo de américa ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniel hablando
los dos de rojo daniela porque pues hay
que celebrar porque ya es viernes y
vamos a hablar justamente de el viernes
negro iniciamos con la fuerte caída de
los mercados y luego hablamos de daxing
ajá raúl muy buenos días y no solamente
sello rosa también está de rojo mejor
dicho de celebración a las que también
están de rojo y no precisamente por
celebración son las bolsas del mundo
raúl todo por cuenta de esta nueva
variante
sudafricana encontrada sobre el virus
del corona virus y los temores sobre lo
que pueda ocurrir pues está tallada en
sudáfrica y llevó a la unión europea a
gran bretaña e india entre otros a
anunciar controles más estrictos e hizo
que las acciones de aerolíneas y de
empresas de turismo se desplomara en
raúl a medida que los inversionistas se
deshacen de sus acciones en estas
compañías en asia por ejemplo la bolsa
de tokio cayó a su nivel más bajo en un
mes y en hong kong al menor nivel en
siete semanas si nos vamos para europa
vemos que los mercados caen entre 2 y 3
siento como no lo hacían hace más de un
año los futuros de eeuu también abrieron
con fuertes descensos del día de hoy
daniela ahora sí y vamos a hablar del
black friday este año muy diferente a
los demás porque pues raúl con el
invitado usted estaba mencionando que la
primera vez se usa el término viernes
negro para describir la quiebra del
mercado de oro en eeuu en 1869 pero
usted sabe cuando se acuñó para el tema
de las compras no señor por favor
explicó mire yo tampoco lo sabía hasta
hace muy poco escuchando a una
historiadora colombiana muy reconocida
que se llama diana uribe y ella decía
que en la época del 60 en filadelfia
pues la gente estaba celebrando se
inscriben como nosotros anoche y el
viernes pues toda la gente no iba a
trabajar decían que seguían enfermos
pero lo que querían era seguir con sus
familias y lo que hacían era salir a
iniciar las compras de navidad por
supuesto las
compañías pues que venden ropa y que
venden accesorios y que venden de todo
lo que hicieron fue hacer ofertas y así
nació él
daniela ya usted hizo sus compras alguna
compra de este viernes negro no sé a qué
horas cuando salgamos de aquí vamos a
hacer nuestra compra si no lo hacemos el
lunes en el cyber monday pero ahora le
pregunto cómo estuvieron entonces las
ventas el año pasado mire no pues este
día comienza oficialmente la temporada
de compras de fin de año y primero
hagamos como un balance de todo lo que
es el black friday en este momento de
pandemia este año es muy diferente
porque está presionado por la crisis
mundial de suministros y los altísimos
precios de los productos que son la
consecuencia de este fenómeno aunque la
gente está volviendo a los almacenes la
escasez de contenedores ha ayudado a
retrasar las entregas y la falta de mano
de obra podrían también generar un
ambiente menos festivo ahora si le
cuento mire un estudio de una firma
mundial llamada criteo data dice que el
viernes en negro del año pasado dejó un
aumento del 139 por ciento en las ventas
globales si se compara con octubre en
eeuu el alza fue mayor y también en
canadá y en américa latina brasil tuvo
el mayor crecimiento porque las ventas
fueron seis veces mayores ahora los
desafíos de este raúl también tienen que
ver con las grandes cadenas minoristas
este viernes activistas por el clima
bloquearon la entrada al centro
logístico más grande de amazon de reino
unido porque dicen que fomenta el
consumo excesivo también hubo protestas
de trabajadores y conductores de reparto
en alemania francia e italia gary ahora
vamos a hablar de uber y bruselas porque
ese servicio de conducción después de
transporte suspendió las operaciones en
bruselas desde las 0 horas de este
viernes está suspendido esta plataforma
de transportes en la capital de bélgica
un tribunal de apelaciones de bruselas
determinó que la prohibición de la
operación que entró en vigencia en 2015
para los particulares que ofrecen
servicios de taxi también opera para
conductores de plataformas como uber por
eso la compañía suspendió los viajes y
sus conductores bloquearon la calle
principal que va desde las instituciones
europeas recordemos que allí queda la
sede principal de la unión europea hasta
el centro de bruselas la empresa dice
que la decisión afectará a unos 2.000
conductores e instó al gobierno a
cambiar las leyes para qué pues les
permitan operar y es que raúl en europa
ha habido varios movimientos
regulatorios sobre uber este año hay
países que ya la obligan a tratar a sus
conductores no como independientes sino
como empleados con todas las
prestaciones como el reino unido por
ejemplo para inmunidad y españa así es
danny pero la crisis de suministro que
también estábamos hablando le pasó
factura a méxico bueno el producto
interno bruto del tercer trimestre en
este país fue del 4.5 por ciento creció
4,5 por ciento y es una buena noticia
pero según los datos del instituto
nacional de estadística si la
comparación se hace frente al trimestre
anterior si se evidencia una contracción
del 0,4 por ciento entre las causas está
la caída del sector de servicios así
como los problemas en la cadena de
suministro que sumados a la alta
inflación son el principal reto para el
banco central que ahora está lidiando
con un cambio de liderazgo el presidente
de méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador
pidió a la población ver con calma los
efectos de esta desaceleración y aseguró
que la economía determinará el año con
un crecimiento del 6 por ciento
no creo vamos a pasar bueno y de
economía vamos a ver a nuestro reportaje
del día ya se lo voy a presentar